Listening to a podcast that said cancer is just parasites. If you clean up the parasites,
you can restore your health. What are your thoughts on this? Well, I totally disagree with
that. And I would be careful listening to anybody out there that says dogmatic statements
like that because cancer is, you know, every different type of cancer is really a different
disease ever one and has different causes. You could have a twin brother that has the
exact same cancer that you do and it could be, you know, totally different cause and
totally different way to correct it. Whatever you see, like, oh, cancer is just a fungus,
you know, somebody wrote a book about cancer too. Cancer isn't even a disease. It's just
a fungus and you have to kill the fungus. So it's just, to me, this is just showing
the person's ignorance, I don't know, sorry, but totally disagree with it. Can parasites be
a part of your ill health? Well, sure, you can have parasites be a part of ill health,
matter what kind of disease process or symptom pattern that you have. So you do want to address
that too. Having reading that beta-glucan is very good to help kill cancer cells. If so, is
there a brand you would recommend? Maybe it is in something I'm taking. I just don't see
it in a gradient list. So beta-glucan is polysaccharide. So polysaccharides are probably my favorite
thing to help stimulate your immune system and kill cancer cells. And because wordy find polysaccharide
so polysaccharides are in mushrooms. Polysaccharides are in aloe. And different chains of polysaccharides do
different things. That's why there's you using different mushrooms can be beneficial. The aloevia
immune product that number of people are on. That's a certain chain of polysaccharides. I think it's
about three to four hundred chains saccharide lakes. There's different chains of polysaccharides that
are in chaga mushrooms, a little bit different chains that are in turkey tail mushrooms. And so you can
also get polysaccharides and beta-glucan is just another polysaccharide. So beta-glucans are a
polysaccharide that are in mushrooms. You could also get beta-glucans from other sources as well.
So if you're taking a mushroom in anything you're taking you are getting beta-glucans. If you want a
pure, just straight, great beta-glucan. My favorite now is the US enzymes beta-glucan product.
That's called, I think that's called a mudo-zine. That's a good beta-glucan product. But so if you're
going to take another subtle beta-glucan, look at that.